could this be the world's first glimpse
of princess latifah in public
in three years she is the daughter of
the ruler of dubai
and in secret video messages released to
sky news in february
she claimed her father was keeping her
hostage
i'm in a villa i'm a hostage
and this villa has been converted into a
jail all the windows are borrowed shut i
can't open any window
her father sheikh mohammed bin rashid al
maktoum
is a powerful and influential man and is
regularly seen alongside heads of state
including the queen he has consistently
denied claims he mistreated his daughter
now two images have been shared that
appear to show her
out and about the first was posted on
instagram
two days ago and was sent to sky news it
appears to show her having coffee at a
dubai mall
there are face masks on the table
suggesting it has been taken recently
and an advert in the background is
promoting a movie
released on the 13th of may
the second shows her with one of the
women at a restaurant in the city
sky news has not been able to
independently verify the images
but understands they are thought to be
legitimate
princess latifa attempted to flee the
uae in 2018
but was brought back to dubai she has
not been seen in public since
campaigners who have been asking for
proof latifah is safe
are cautious it's important to state
what this photograph
doesn't show it seems to show she's
alive
but it doesn't show whether she's free
and it doesn't show
the conditions of her confinement her
family have repeatedly said
princess latifah is safe and well but
for some
it will take more than still photos to
convince them
sanya burgess sky news